ahna we'd love that you became the queen
of arendelle at the end of frozen - but
no one is happier than Elsa because well
she never really wanted to rule in the
first place
but now that she's the ruler of the
Enchanted Forest you're in charge and we
can't wait to see what you do with the
kingdom and Kristoff will make a
wonderful ruler - but while some things
never change like your love for Olaf
Kristoff Sven and Elsa frozen three is
going to shake things up like never
before
frozen three has yet to be confirmed but
that hasn't stopped us from cooking up a
storyline for the three cool keep
watching as we reveal what we think will
happen in frozen three frozen two ended
with Ana's coronation but many of us
were left wondering if Anna and Kristoff
had gotten married yet fans want to see
Anna walk down the aisle so if it was up
to us frozen three we begin with a royal
wedding we want to see what Ana's
wedding dress is going to look like and
we also want to see the look on Chris
Sasuke's when she makes her grand
slow-motion entrance frozen three would
start on a high note the kingdom of
arendelle would be thriving and then the
soldier tribe would be to span would be
king Christoph's best man and Elsa would
be on as maid of honor
if you thought frozen to was visually
stunning wait until you set your sights
on the royal wedding we just hope that
on on Christoph get to sing their vows
to each other they're long overdue for
romantic duet it would be so much better
than on and on song love is an open door
everyone loves a royal wedding so
spirits would be at an all-time high in
arendelle but if there's one thing we've
learned from frozen - it's that all
things do eventually change
arendelle has always been a peaceful
place well except for that time elsa set
off an eternal winter Oh and that time
Hans tried to crown himself as king and
let's not forget that time Gale chased
everyone out of arendelle and into the
mountains okay maybe it's not the most
peaceful place but it will be once Queen
Anna and King Christophe
are calling the shots however something
big will happen that will put both the
enchanted forest
and the kingdom of arendelle at risk and
we think that frozen 3 will sense her
around this keep watching to find out
about the big bad of frozen 3 the best
storyteller that ever lived by now we
all know that Olaf is the best
storyteller in the Disney verse he
filled the lost arendelle soldiers and
then the Soulja tribe in on the events
of frozen and he did the same for else's
baby snowman in the post-credits scene
of frozen - unfortunately for Olaf his
stories might be what leads to outsiders
trying to take over the enchanted forest
let us explain Olaf is getting older
he's becoming more curious and just like
Elsa he's going to want to venture into
the unknown
perhaps Olaf will travel the world and
share his stories with the people he
meets on the road and while most people
don't believe in magic and elemental
spirits these stories are way more
convincing when they come from a talking
snowman
so eventually these stories will be told
all over the world which might bring
unwanted attention to the kingdom of
arendelle and its surrounding
neighborhoods the frozen franchise has
totally flipped the script on the common
Disney movie instead of solely focusing
on villains Disney concentrated on the
emotional journeys of their main
characters sure some villains popped up
along the way but none of them were all
that threatening we mean come on Hans
he's not a villain he's a simple-minded
buffoon with a badly hatched plan and
then there's AG nurse father the man
responsible for angering the spirits of
the forest but he hardly showed his face
in frozen - so we wouldn't exactly call
him a villain we don't know about you
but we'd love to see Elsa go up against
someone who has powers of their own and
that's what we think will happen in
frozen 3 Olaf stories will reach the
ears of a very evil man a man who wants
power more than anything
so he'll find a way to
- the magic from the enchanted forest
and he'll become just as powerful as
Elsa if not more
once he steals the magical abilities of
the four elemental spirits he'll go
after Elsa and boy what a showdown that
will be but more on that later if
there's one thing we want to know more
about its Queen I Dunas pass we know
that she belonged to one of the oldest
families of the mythology tribe but
that's pretty much all we know the
arendelle soldiers and the mythology ins
were trapped in the forest for 34 years
but surely some if I do Nizam leme uh
still be alive
but we think that Yelena is related to
on and Elsa through her mother's side of
the family she was ready to attack Elsa
and her crew when they first crossed the
fog barrier in frozen - but the second
she saw I do know scarf she immediately
changed her tune and since Yelena is the
leader of her people she must belong to
an ancient family - we expect Elsa and
Yelena to become very close in frozen
three and maybe just maybe Yelena will
reveal herself to be I do nez mother
Elsa and Ana's grandmother how cool
would that be we would love for Elsa and
Anna to meet some of their long-lost
family members after all all they have
is each other in terms of family members
do you love hearing about the latest
Disney news and theories then subscribe
to the things and let the good times
roll if you want to be the first to
comment on our videos click that bell
and turn on those post notifications if
you're watching on your mobile turn on
notifications in your YouTube settings
this way you'll never miss another video
falling in love has never been one of
Elsa's priorities and frozen she was too
busy trying to accept her true self and
in frozen - she was preoccupied with the
journeying into the unknown and finding
her true calling but there is nothing
like watching your younger sister get
married to make you realize that it's
time to put yourself out there we
definitely weren't the only ones who
noticed sparks flying between Elsa and
honey Maren and frozen - so
if we had to choose a future partner for
Elsa it would totally be her Elsa and
honey Merrin might fall in love in
frozen 3
but unfortunately for Elsa this will be
used against her remember that evil man
we talked about earlier in the video you
know the one who's going to attack the
forest and steal the powers of the four
elemental spirits
well we think he's going to realize that
he's no match for Elsa
so he'll choose to kidnap honey Maren
and use her against her he'll propose a
trade Elsa's powers for honey Marans
life but we'll also choose to save honey
Maren and give up her powers keep
watching to find out before we reveal
what will happen at the end of frozen 3
we think it's important to mention that
honour and Elsa will grow apart in the
three cool but don't worry their bond
will become stronger than ever by the
end of the third film now that Anna is
the queen of arendelle she's one busy
lady and so is Elsa she's the official
ruler of the Enchanted Forest after all
despite being super close and frozen to
these two sisters will eventually grow
apart
Elsa will fall in love and start
spending a lot of her free time with
honey Maren and she'll start missing her
weekly charade parties with Kristoff
Olaf and Anna honorable thing that she
did something wrong and Elsa will feel
the same but all that will change when
Anna finds out that the Enchanted Forest
is under attack arendelle will defend
the forests once upon a time the people
of the forest saw the arendelle soldiers
as their only threat but those days are
long gone now the people of the forests
view of the arendelle soldiers as their
allies and vice versa when honey Maren
gets kidnapped rider will escape and run
to arendelle to tell the King and Queen
about what happens and Anna and Kristoff
will round up the troops and defend the
Enchanted Forest problem is there really
isn't anything that Anna and Kristoff
can do because their enemy will be much
too powerful at this point but the fact
that honour rushes to Elsa side will be
all it takes to mend their sisterly bond
on
we'll find out that Elsa has been
distancing herself because she's in love
which will make honest super happy Anna
will be there to console Elsa when she
finds out that honey Marin has been
kidnapped and she'll be there to help
her make an impossible choice
her powers or honey Marin the ultimate
sacrifice so we hate to break it to you
guys but one of Elsa's closest friends
isn't going to survive but before we
tell you who let's jump right into the
final battle the big bag of frozen 3 is
going to wield a magical amulet which is
what allows him to steal the elements
powers in the first place all Elsa has
to do is break that amulet and the
powers will return to their rightful
owners problem is the villain has honey
Marin as a hostage and Elsa isn't about
to risk honey meirin's life so Elsa
agrees to give up her powers we know
pretty crazy right but like most
villains Elsa's enemy goes back on his
word he steals her powers and tries to
end else's life by sending a blast of
ice her way and that's when yelena jumps
in front of Elsa sacrificing herself in
the process it's a really sad moment but
Yelena sacrifice serves as an element of
surprise and honey Marin pounces on the
villain stealing his magical amulet and
breaking it the arendelle soldiers and
then the soldier tribe attacked the evil
man and his henchmen putting an end to
his rule then we flash forward to honey
Marin Elsa Kristoff and Anna playing
couples charades it's on his turn to go
up and she places her hands on her belly
and that's when Kristoff yells pregnant
that's how Anna breaks the news to them
so frozen four could totally be about
the next generation of arendelle and
that's a wrap on what will happen in
frozen 3 before you go tell us what you
think will happen in the three coal and
be sure to tell us what you would name
Kristoff and Ana's baby thanks for
watching and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll catch you
next time on the things